So we just spent a lot of time talking about domain, range, and all sorts of
functions. I'd like to do a sort of review quiz over what a function really is
conceptually. We've talked about this in a lot of different contexts. Solving
this would be a good way to bridge the many different things that you're learned
about functions. So which of these choices correctly describe functions? You can
check off as many as you like. Does a function map each element of the domain to
at least one element of the range? Does it map each element of the domain to
exactly one element of the range? Does it relate a set of inputs to a set of
outputs? Does it have to have a defined value for any real number that we want
to use as input? And is a function the same as any equation with two variables?